and i learned a lot man you gotta
if you don't try to integrate everybody
you can learn cool cultural things like
i learned a lot of things about like
black culture
right like communication is very
different
for example white people whisper
i grew up in white schools and i never
understood white people would be like
hey oh gosh
make it out of my ear man what the [ __ ]
are you saying
that morse code i don't know what you're
talking about
my black friends never whispered
what my black friends are doing they
want to tell me something was look
around
and then they would lean back and then
mumble whatever they needed to say
i'm gonna be honest
made more sense to me communication
black laughter also very different
right here's an example not every black
person laughs like this that would be
racist
but only black people have this laugh
right here
it took an adjustment it used to bother
me you know i mean
because i'm a comedian by nature i want
to hear it
i don't get this [ __ ] sprinkler
system
emphysema yeah copd
it's okay to make noise when you laugh
but then i realize it's all good because
when black people do make noise and they
laugh it's the best
it's interactive experience you got to
be ready
because if you're nearby whatever's
nearby
is taking abuse
at least getting a nice shake
they used to mess me up i wasn't ready
but it's way more fun dude you just
gotta know how to handle it this is
let me tell you something portland i
know you're trying to integrate a lot if
you guys make a black friend you
probably haven't had any before but if
you make a black glass
and something funny happens here's what
you got to do
i wish there was a wall is there a wall
i don't want to pretend this is my black
friend because that feels a little
racist
but all right this is a curtain all
right that's what we got to do guys this
is what we got
let's pretend for a second this is my
black friend i wish it wasn't
like this but as
soon as the funny thing happens you just
gotta lean into your friend
real hard don't stop leaning
okay because here's the thing i'm indian
enough to know
that torque equals force times distance
so you take distance down to here it's a
whole different ballgame you get
distance out here
you're on the pirate ship at six flags
this is just a nice gentle rock